CHET HAASE: Hi.
I'm Chet Haase, an engineer on
the Android Team at Google.
Today I wanted to talk a little
bit about bitmaps.
In particular, I want to talk
about bitmap scaling.
One of the big problems that
people run into when running
applications on constrained
devices is that they want to
load in, let's say, huge images
from the camera on the
phone, from the web, wherever.
And when they're loading in
a lot of these things, A,
they're going to take a
long time to come in.
B, they're going to create
garbage along the way and
performance problems.
And C, maybe they're going to
run out of memory if they try
to load too many at
the same time.
There are various ways of
dealing with this situation.
The overarching idea is that you
should load and create and
use the images of the
size you need.
So for example, don't load in
an image that's this big if
you're always going to display
it as a thumbnail.
Instead, load in whatever you
need to, get it at the size
you need it, and then
have that be the
image that you retain.
So today's example is
around loading in a
scaled version of it.
In particular, we're going to
use a parameter in Bitmap
Factory Options, which is
called inSample Size.
So first let's take a look at
the demo, which is called
Bitmap Scaling.
And there's nothing to
interact with here.
I just wanted to show a visual
representation of what's going
on with these images.
Because there's something
a little unobvious about
inSample Size the first
time you use it.
So the original image you can
see up at the top under the
words that say Original Image.
And then you can see these
scaled versions down below
where it says Scaled Images.
So we see two of the same size
and then four of the same size
and then two of the same
size under there.
So what's going on?
Let's take a look at the code.
So we have this class called
Bitmap Scaling.
We have this image view where
we're going to find the
original image.
We're going to decode
the Jelly Bean
statue image in there.
And then we're going to add
scaled image views.
And this is going to be using
the inSample Size thing.
So we're basically going to
iterate values from 2 to 10
and use that as our inSample
Size value and see
what effect we get.
So we create one of these Bitmap
options objects and we
set the inSample Size to the
sample size that was passed
in, which is that integer
value from 2 to 10.
And then we create a scaled
bitmap, which does a decode on
that original image.
But it uses the options.
It uses this inSample Size.
And what inSample Size tells it
is how many pixels to read
for each of the original
pixels in the image.
The advantage of doing
it this way is that
it reads less data.
It's going to be faster to do
this because it's basically
skipping a lot of data along the
way potentially based on
the value of inSample Size.
The disadvantage of doing it is
that it's basically going
to wind up with powers of 2
scales of your original image.
So you can pass in a value of
2, which means it's going to
skip every other pixel, and
you're going to wind up with
an image that's half the
size of the original.
If you ask for 3, it's
happy to do that.
Except it doesn't really
make sense.
It's actually going to round
down to the next lowest power
of 2 and it's going to be
equivalent to 2, which is why
we see, for the first 2
scaled images, they're
exactly the same size.
Because passing in 3 was
equivalent to passing in 2.
When we go up to 4, that's
the next power of 2.
OK, it's happy to do that.
When we go up to 5, it
rounds down to 4.
So basically, inSample Size is
a very coarse-grained way of
getting a scaled image.
It works great in the cases
where you want powers of 2
scales of your original image.
Maybe it works for you to read
in at that lower size and you
get a faster reading time,
because you're
reading less data.
But then once you have that
data, maybe you then want to
scale to the exact size
that you want.
And you can always get a bitmap
of the exact size that
you want through various
mechanisms.
Creating it exactly at the
width-height that you want or
create a scaled bitmap.
There's an API to create
a scaled bitmap
from another one.
So there's lots of different
ways to do that.
Today was about using inSample
Size in particular.
Higher performance because it
reads less data with the
constraint that it will end
up with powers of 2
images at the end.
So inSample Size.
Use it.
Thanks.